Lots of people believe in the possibility
of “past lives”, the notion that the life
we are currently living is not our first.
Before you were the person you are now, sitting
at home and watching this video, maybe you
were a Medieval king, a Renaissance painter,
or an ancient Spartan warrior.
Past Life Regression is a controversial practice
that allows people to look back at their supposed
past lives, looking through the eyes of someone
in another lifetime.
It’s a nice idea, and there’s something
exciting about the possibility of reliving
the experiences of a person from the past.
And wouldn’t you know it, the SCP Foundation
just so happened to discover an artifact that
allows a person to experience another person’s
memories.
It is not past life regression, and you have
no control over whose life you are peeking
into, but it allows you to look at the world
through their eyes.
However, when you look through someone else’s
eyes, there’s always the possibility that
you will see something you didn’t want to.
Something troubling, frightening, even traumatic.
Or worse.
So you may not want to subject yourself to
SCP-1123, or, as it has been ominously nicknamed,
The Atrocity Skull.
SCP-1123 is an old human skull with no teeth
or lower jaw.
Across the forehead region of the skull, the
Khmer word for “remember” is written in
blood.
Testing of the skull and blood determined
it was from the 1970s, and that both the blood
and skull belonged to the same person.
The Atrocity Skull was discovered by a Colonel
in the Vietnamese People’s Army in the 1980s,
as part of a collection of human remains displayed
in a Cambodian museum.
Struck by the bloody writing, and the peculiar
feeling that the skull gave him, the Colonel
decided to send it to Hanoi for further investigation.
While in transit though, the skull was intercepted…
by the SCP Foundation.
Foundation Agents set a trap along the road,
blowing out the tires of the Colonel’s transportation.
The skull was taken and sent to a Foundation
facility, and the Colonel was given an amnestic
to remove all memory of the skull’s discovery.
The staff of the Cambodian museum received
a similar treatment.
All written mentions of the skull were erased,
and now outside of the Foundation’s archives,
there is no official record of the skull ever
having existed.
The bloody writing on the skull has faded
over time and from a distance is barely visible
at all.
The first SCP Foundation agent to study the
skull, an unknown researcher whose name has
since been scrubbed from the Foundation archives,
had a series of unusual experiences while
observing the skull.
He reported that the script was invisible
from five meters away.
As he approached it, he noted that the writing
became clearer with each meter he got closer
until at one meter away, the writing looked
fresh.
Unable to stop himself, he reached out to
touch it, and found that his fingers came
away slick and red.
Somehow, the bloody writing was still wet,
as if it had been drawn only moments before.
As soon as he touched the text, he began to
experience anomalous sensory phenomena.
The room filled with the smell of smoke, he
could hear the sound of heavy breathing, and
the pounding of a heartbeat.
There were thundering footsteps behind him,
and he turned to look, but found nothing there.
He jerked his hand back away from the skull,
recoiling at the sensation of ants crawling
over the back of his hand.
His eyes began to sting, as if filled with
ash, and he stumbled backward, only to fall
to the ground from a sudden stabbing sensation,
like a shard of glass piercing his shoe and
the sole of his foot.
The researcher was removed from the room and
examined by a physician, who found that none
of these sensations had accompanying physical
symptoms.
They were purely psychosomatic, so it seemed.
There was nothing in his eyes, no wound on
his foot.
Contact with the skull had caused him to experience
these physical stimuli, but it was all in
his head.
And this was far from the full extent of SCP-1123’s
impact on those who interacted with it.
After several weeks untouched, the skull was
examined by yet another Foundation researcher.
When she touched the surface of the skull
to lift it and take a closer look, she fell
into a dissociative fugue state - a kind of
distressing altered state of consciousness.
She became confused, disoriented, and wouldn’t
respond to her name.
The skull was removed from her grasp as soon
as she became unresponsive, but this did nothing
to return her to normal.
The accompanying researchers simply had to
observe her and wait for her to wake up.
Six hours later, when she finally did, she
recounted what she experienced after touching
the skull.
She claimed that she had seen the life of
another person in the time between touching
the skull and returning to consciousness.
She could recount details of this other person’s
life, describing places she had never been,
events she had never witnessed, and even speaking
a language she had previously demonstrated
no command of.
The other researchers determined that the
person described actually had existed, though
they had since passed away, and that all the
little details were too specific to be a simple
coincidence.
After this encounter with SCP-1123, several
other researchers experienced similarly traumatic
fugue states.
The Foundation was able to identify several
shared characteristics among those who touched
the skull and experienced the life of another
person.
All of the people whose memories were seen
by test subjects died before the subject was
born, were a victim of violence or imprisonment,
died in a tragic or violent way by murder,
starvation, or infection, and died as a result
of being targeted by a political movement.
These patterns led to the coining of the SCP’s
nickname, The Atrocity Skull.
It is a skull that forces those who touch
it to relive past atrocities.
In order to further understand the nature
of the skull’s effects on test subjects
and the nature of the lives it imprints on
them, a series of experiments were performed
by the Foundation.
Various people of differing cultural backgrounds
were exposed to the skull, in an attempt to
determine what correlation, if any, there
is between someone exposed to the skull and
the type of person whose memories they experience.
In the first experiment, a man of Irish and
French ancestry was told to touch the skull.
He immediately collapsed, and began to scream
in Armenian and resist any and all assistance
from Foundation officers.
When he returned to full consciousness, he
explained that he had taken on the memories
of an Armenian farmer who was burned alive
by the Ottoman army in 1915 during the Armenian
Genocide.
During a different experiment, a man with
Haitian ancestry touched the skull.
Just before touching it, he complained of
a chemical smell and a powerful itching sensation.
After he touched it, he began to violently
cough.
His fugue state lasted for 60 minutes, and
was characterized by confusion and a sudden
ability to speak Kurdish.
After waking up from the fugue state, the
man was able to describe the imprinted personality
of an 85 year victim of a mustard gas attack
in Iraq in 1989.
A third experiment involved a woman with Chinese
ancestry, who became unresponsive for over
two hours after touching the skull.
She was clearly distressed and began to loudly
weep as the time progressed.
Once the two hours were up, she was able to
give an interview where she described her
experience while in the fugue state.
She experienced the life of a young Ukrainian
girl who died in 1932 as a result of violence
at the hands of a Soviet brigade.
Several other experiments were also conducted,
producing similar results.
Each time, the subject would experience a
fugue state lasting from around an hour to
upwards of six hours.
The experiments allowed the Foundation to
determine some statistical patterns in the
personalities and memories experienced by
test subjects.
The more victims that can be attributed to
a historical event, the more likely it is
that a test subject will experience the memories
of someone killed in that event.
There is no apparent correlation between the
nationality of the test subject and the nationality
of the person whose memories they will live
through.
While there are no negative physical effects
on test subjects who have come into contact
with the skull, there is a notable psychological
impact which can be attributed to the traumatic
nature of the memories that they were exposed
to during the course of the experiment.
Subjects have demonstrated bouts of grief
and depression, as well as struggles with
survivor’s guilt.
Though they themselves did not survive the
events that they witnessed, they feel as though
they did.
In an attempt to alleviate these psychological
effects, the Foundation administered several
types of amnestics to test subjects.
However, these were not effective and in many
cases, they were actively harmful.
The SCP Foundation uses a variety of amnestic
compounds as a part of its work, but none
of them were effective in treating test subjects
who had been exposed to SCP 1123.
Class B Amnestics, or Regressive Retrograde,
remove the most recently formed memories from
a person’s mind.
When these were administered to SCP 1123 test
subjects, their own memories began to fade
away, while the memories of their imprinted
personality remained intact.
If the dosage was increased, only the memories
of the atrocity would remain.
Other amnestics with similar functions yielded
similar, and equally troubling results.
The wrong memories would disappear, and the
subject’s original personality would begin
to give way to that of the person the skull
had imprinted on them.
And so another type of amnestic was applied
in an attempt to solve this issue.
Class E amnestics, or Ennui, do not remove
memories from the subject’s mind, but rather
lessen the subject’s emotional response
to them.
They are intended to weaken neural pathways
and remove the emotional component from a
given memory, reducing the subject’s stress
or trauma response to the information of said
memory.
All of the science behind this class of amnestic
suggests that it would be beneficial to the
test subjects involved in this research, but
for some reason they were still ineffective.
The application of Class E amnestics to test
subjects following exposure to the Atrocity
Skull only worsened the subject’s trauma
response, contributing to panic attacks, flashbacks,
and other symptoms of severe Post-Traumatic
Stress Disorder.
Eventually, the use of amnestics to benefit
these test subjects was abandoned entirely.
Experimentation with the skull was placed
on hold until a beneficial treatment program
for the test subjects could be established.
Currently, to preserve the condition of the
skull and the writing on its surface, SCP-1123
is kept contained in a hermetically sealed
container in an argon gas atmosphere.
When it is removed from containment for experimentation
and testing, it is kept in light at no more
than 50 lux, with the temperature inside the
container kept between 20 and 24 degrees Celsius,
and 55% humidity.
No one is permitted to handle the skull under
any circumstances except for controlled experimentation.
There is a saying that says those who do not
learn from history are doomed to repeat it.
As distressing as the experience of touching
SCP-1123 may be, perhaps there is a use for
it.
Confronting historical atrocities directly,
and looking through the eyes of their victims,
is a stark reminder of all the evil that humanity
is capable of.
Certainly the history reflected by the Atrocity
Skull, imprinted directly into the minds of
all who touch it, will not be soon forgotten.
Those who have touched it, those who speak
to them, and all who learn about the impact
of the Atrocity Skull, should take care to
remember history.
To learn from it.
To make sure that these evils are never repeated
again.
Perhaps, we will even reach a point where
we do not have to look through the eyes of
the victims of institutionalized evil.
We will simply have moved beyond it.
Then, and only then, will it be time for the
skull to be destroyed.
Until then, it remains preserved in the halls
of the SCP Foundation as a reminder that,
amidst all of the horrors contained in those
walls, sometimes the greatest monster is us.
Now go check out “SCP-4205 - In The Eyes
of the Beholder” and “SCP-3999 - I Am
At The Center of Everything That Happens To
Me” for more strange and haunting SCPs!